hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play dis potentia i
think it's pronounced I'm not exactly
sure this is welcome to a session to
familiarize with discipline and boss
dead in a mansion in the hamlet called
Carl fours and Sweden another one in
Sweden this story is based on real
events that allegedly occurred inside
the Manzon how can it be real if they
allegedly occurred I'm an ignore it
I'll allow it press Continue if you dare
to witness and relive every hearsay
about dis ponent
boss Dadon despondent opposed I didn't
ok
this is a relatively new mod a lot of
people were like you got a plague of a
goblet so I am going to play it ooh I
like that it finally copied all my
settings from before dis bone area
that's it amnesia despondency aha
well let's get to it shall we
hello that I don't even know I'm kind of
curious if this all takes place in just
the one house I'm not exactly sure like
once again normally when I go into these
things I don't do a lot of research
beforehand so it's a full conversion mod
I know that it's actually got custom
textures as you could see with the car
and the house there in a long loading
screen but we'll get by that any day now
any day now hmm what's going on
I hope it didn't freeze I'm hoping this
is just an exorbitant ly long loading
time a music is definitely custom which
I like I like it when people try custom
things okay here we go finally Mackay
boy presents
interesting despondency ah
I like it for centuries urban stories
surrounding the hamlet car force and its
neighbor mansion despondent post Arden
discipline and both dead the quiet
forest clad mountains that surround Carl
fors is just the scattered Lakes making
it as picturesque as it can be even
though the area is haunted by darkness
any local and you will hear ask any
local he would hear proof of the
widespread superstition any here's day
about this pond birthday and says that a
visitor once passed away in US alone
while talking on the phone in a
thunderstorm
his body rot by its tainted soul has
left him disfigured of empty presence
but the energy of his spirit still
remains many assert that they have
experienced supernatural phenomena and
felt as if they were being observed and
Bobby another claim that they have sent
some kind of dark energy an energy which
because their will to live - just
evanesce away it is said that those who
encounter disappear will be consumed by
its fury
regardless of how the framing story if
you decide to spend the night alone in
dimension uh I'm fast I like it I like
it a lot wait does this all take place
in a single mansion Oh what this is
awesome
the door is deadlocked you mean from the
inside should not do something about
that be there standing it out it's bad
for you whoa it's probably bad idea to
go in here Wow Oh what
hahahahaha what the heck was that
I didn't even notice a girl all of them
look at the beginning oh man oh oh I do
not like this mod it is off to a
terrifying start was there something
behind
I saw woods wind swirling around that
bookshelf what the heck oh hello Vanja
give me oil and sanity potion let's go
to me oh man ha ha ha what is happening
to me
don't even know I don't even know I
don't even know
oh man I am so freaked out right now oh
it again welcome to this point in Boston
then I have left some bonjah cookies in
the freezer which you are allowed to eat
if you out the house has recently been
cleaned so please do not make him is it
will come back on Saturday to clean up
further when the chiral fours company we
see visitors from Brazil I have reserved
room to be for you good luck
why would I need luck if you're just
welcoming me kind regards and maybe
right
dd-do I don't like this what doc you
better go to sleep before you get too
tired it'll be a long day I don't think
sleepy I'll just bones
Oh skulls I don't even think sleeping is
a good idea right now after what I just
saw so now I'm holed up on that I've
found like a lantern or anything those
red candles sure are warm and reassuring
this door uh-huh ah ah light
oh it's lights oh that's wonderful maybe
I was this nice nice nice
I've done open up there we are
gives open Hey look toilet pick new
shirts in a bathroom that makes total
sense
boink okay nothing in there um look I
perfectly normal perfectly normal stuff
eh ah ha ha that's much better this one
doesn't seem to be working
oh yeah it's the same one ok ha ha
keys to B now take 2 C as well to see or
not to be blah blah blah oh man it's
like freaking insane
the atmosphere is crazy good I mean
maybe it's just the fact that I feel
like I'm in a haunted house wasn't like
a tiny I was like a tiny thing of oil
yeah oh no I think not I'll just keep
going on my merry way
and you can f off this Oasis
what our failures oh when I have enough
sailors you can open chest containing
valuable items
hahaha that's interesting
you're giving me all this oil I would
really love a lantern or something
that'd be nice Oh turned off the light
oh those lights are not very good at all
all right so still going that me what is
that okay that's me up books blown over
in the wind not scary
not even it is gear I'm not gonna lose
my tinder box what that hello tinder box
huh thank you I sell it up here I no
idea I need to find a lantern I'm gonna
get down
ahh I caught it on the slush up by a
dice oh hello chairs I see something
back there give me thank you God I do
not like this place oh it is so freaky
it is so so freaky here there's dead
bodies get body dead body
I don't even bother to close up what's
up hi thought I saw something the
basement um okay good I didn't want to
go down there anyway Oh dead body catch
up haunted catch up
oh it could be that exploding ketchup
from the number nothing man
yeah first I thought there wasn't gonna
be much just going through now just this
one house but this house is actually
pretty big and has a lot of stuff in it
for damn sure
where am I oh I'm back in the entrance
okay oh man definitely got the
atmosphere shirts what's with all the
shirts haha loud down hahaha down and
down ha ha ha ha ha that's funny you
funny guy you funny you should find now
down down oh you're also terrifying guy
out there ah more now down no no
doubt down a number okay that's it for
first floor and they can't get to the
basement yet so let's go upstairs
Oh what is that ceiling fan ha ha ha
what what must break - [ __ ]
oh this is like the landscape what with
that whoa whoa Wow okay Hot Diggity ah
sailors enough failures is that Swedish
money no that's the Crone or or no
that's sweet
I thought these chests were spud tab
work nice with taupe just like this week
you know the Taylors I don't know maybe
this isn't the Taylor place quickly I
gotta remember to look for the lights
ah blower blowing open in the wind calm
down
oh yeah light switch light switch check
click that's so bright nice in here
I think in here oh man
this is free gay oh oh it's gold
give me those some of these things are
like you know it's at like a skull or
something oh the other everything else
is just like unsettling everything is
not happy fun times whoa whoa what what
how does that even happen
I like did a super jump huh my legs are
so strong you know how quiet thousand
pounds normally yeah watch myself in the
air
this looks bad
I'm not even gonna lie and say this was
good
ha ha ha ha no no no shut up top
oh how do you like that okay haha Oh
footprints
someone's been tracking mud is that
where that moose man I think it was just
went by real quick
and look up dead bird what the the
saloon so what that person died
alright I'm actually gonna hold off on
reading that for just a second was that
children's books dead dog creaky
floorboards anyway that's actually all
the time I got for this episode this
thoroughly thoroughly freaky place I do
not like this place at all
it's like unbelievably freaky but anyway
this is gonna be a great great great
playthrough I can already tell so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next part
bye-bye